jeremy derek is standing down as the
chief executive
of sky he'll be replaced by dhana strong
an executive with sky's
parent company comcast let's go live to
the city our business presenter ian king
is there hi to you ian do you know why
he's moving on
well he's been chief executive of sky
calling for 13 years which is an
extraordinary
uh long period of time uh sky floated on
the stock market uh
26 years ago and jeremy darrick has been
chief executive for
nearly half of that time and obviously
was taken over by comcast at the end of
2018
for 30 billion so it's an extraordinary
long tenure but anyone's uh stretch of
the imagination the average ftse 100
chief executive
is only in the job for five years also
and i think mr derrick feels that uh
having
overseen the integration of sky into the
broader comcast
business this is now a good time for him
to be stepping aside and uh concentrate
on other opportunities he has a lot of
other
interests outside of the business he has
for example been an ambassador
for the uh wwf the world wildlife fund
and he's also currently chairman of
business in the community which is a
role
that he's had for three years as well as
serving on the boards of burberry and
marx and spencer so i suspect
he will be looking to cast his eye
further afield in the meantime colin
jeremy derek will be becoming executive
chairman
of sky and that's in order to uh oversee
a seamless transition
and after that he will remain an adviser
to the business so he is not walking
away entirely now in the press release
that's been put out jeremy darrock says
it's been a privilege to lead sky for 13
years and an experience that i've looked
forward to every day
so the decision to leave has not been
easy but with the business now firmly
settled into the wider comcast
corporation and a strong plan in place
now is the right time i feel incredibly
lucky to have been surrounded by
colleagues who care as deeply as i do
about the business
and our customers and work who work
tirelessly every day
to make their lives better now he will
be uh
very sorely missed i don't think there's
any question about that he's overseen
a huge expansion of sky during his time
at the helm the business has trebled in
size it's now europe's biggest pay tv
and broadband provider with some 24
million customers he oversaw of course
the takeovers of sister companies sky
italia and sky deutschland
in 2014 as well as launching a whole
panoply of new products and services
including sky
hd sky q sky go now tv he took the
business into streaming
and of course he's overseen an enormous
expansion in
production as well at the business guy
recently announced
a big expansion of uh film studios at l
street in which the company is going to
be investing something like three
billion pounds
over the next five years so he's been a
very very influential
chief executive in the media sector and
of course worth pointing out he did
oversee that takeover
of sky by comcast just over two years
ago
which uh saw the company forming uh part
of the world's one of the
world's biggest entertainment companies
and uh no
mean feat to have achieved all of that
so as i say it's been a very
distinguished uh
period at the helm of skye he's only the
fifth chief executive
of sky since this business floated on
the stock market in
1994 and as i say by far and away the
longest serving it
has been quite some tenure now donna
strong who is
his successor donna strong is currently
president of consumer services
at comcast cable as you said colin
that's a
part of the wider comcast empire and uh
that business is currently america's
largest broadband
and uh pay tv provider she's also worked
extensively
in other parts of the industry for many
years working for liberty media liberty
global which is of course the parent
company
of virgin media where she was chief
operating officer
she holds both australian and american
citizenship because she worked for eight
years
running one of australia's leading
satellite tv providers and she's also
more recently worked as a head of upc
ireland which is liberty's irish pay tv
and satellite business and of course
ireland is a very very key market for
sky as well so
she knows the media landscape
exceptionally well worth pointing out
colin very interestingly one of the
things that
she's been doing during her time at
comcast cable is running a programme to
get
internet connectivity to low-paid
american households
and to that extent uh she's overseen the
signing up of some eight million
americans to the internet during her
time at the helm so uh there's a wider
sort of societal
piece there that she's uh she's played a
part in there
uh i can tell you uh there's a statement
from donna strong on the uh
press release as well she says there are
a few businesses that have the track
record of sky
and i'm delighted to have the
opportunity to lead the company
i've always admired skye's innovation
brand and exceptional focus on the
customer
i look forward to working with this
incredible team to continue to grow the
business
and shape the next chapter for sky and
there are also
words from brian roberts of course who's
the chairman and chief executive of
comcast as well and the man of course
who oversaw that takeover
of sky back in 2018.